quel président Monsieur les commissaires
il faut du courage pour soutenir
inconditionnellement le peuple prégnien
comme la Lituanie la toujours fait il
faut du courage pour ouvrir ses
frontières en accueillant et protégeant
les opposants au régime dictatorial de
Louka chez Nico il faut du courage pour
s'affirmer face à un voisin russe
belliqueux au menaces expansionniste il
faut du courage pour Tony tête à
l'autoritarisme chinois il faut du
courage pour ne jamais tourner le doigt
à ses alliés ce courage votre pays l'a
eu votre peuple l'incarne votre pays
nous a montré ce que certains ne
voulaient et ne veulent toujours pas
voir que la souveraineté nationale est
renforcée par la solidarité européenne
votre pays démontre ce que certains
rejettent qu'une plus grande unité
européenne et synonyme de protection de
nos valeurs et de nos concitoyens oui
l'Union européenne doit rester toujours
unie c'est pourquoi vous l'avez évoqué
un instrument anticoercession fort
réactif effectif ne pouvant être bloqués
par un État membre est un impératif oui
c'est une nécessité que de pouvoir
réagir que de pouvoir nous protéger
quand des États tiers cherchent à
limiter notre liberté monsieur le
Président votre pays et les Lituaniens
montrent qu'agir en européen et la seule
voie qui permette de défendre la
démocratie de répondre aux enjeux
d'aujourd'hui de bâtir notre autonomie
stratégique face à la pandémie nous
avons agi en européen l'achat groupé de
vaccins le transfert de patients est un
membre l'adoption du plan de relance
à l'agression illégale et injustifiée de
l'Ukraine nous agissons en européen
sanctions aide macro-financière
fournitures d'armes face à la crise
énergétique nous continuons d'agir en
européen création de nouvelles lignes
d'approvisionnement réinvestissement
dans de nouvelles énergies vertes
fond social climat face aux sirènes de
la division nous devons continuer d'agir
en européen renforçant le dialogue entre
nos sociétés renforçons le dialogue
entre nos états renforçons le dialogue
avec les États tiers continuons à agir
en européen souverain et solidaires car
pour sortir des dépendances critiques
pour nourrir nos concitoyens pour
relever le défi de la transition
climatique pour ne laisser personne de
côté nous devions dialoguer progresser
mais surtout agir ensemble au Parlement
nous y sommes prêts à nous de suivre
cette voie la voix que votre peuple
dresse pour que ces actions ne restent
pas sans réponse que nous soyons
collectivement à la hauteur des
préoccupations et des aspirations de
tous les Européens et permettez-moi de
monsieur le Président aussi de dire
alors que mon collègue Nicolas B c'est
est déjà quitté l'hémicycle et n'a pas
dit un mot pour votre pays collé
français ne se situeront jamais sur les
lignes défendues par le rassemblement
national et tous les extrêmes merci à
vous
merci Madame